so viel freiheit wie heute waren nie
zumindest in unserer westlichen welt
können hier nahezu alles nennen
müsli oder brot zum frühstück beides
geht kinder karriere oder lieber keins
von beidem ihre wahl autos oder gläubig
privatsache dennoch fühlen wir uns
manchmal umfrage und fragen uns leben
wir wirklich das leben das ihr leben
wollen
dann schreiben wir tagebuch lesen
coaching bücher oder geben uns einer
midlife-crisis hin oder wir diskutieren
die frage hier am tisch und genau das
wollen wir jetzt tun mit bt rösler
sie hat dieses buch geschrieben
autonomie versuch über das gelungene
liebe herzlich willkommen frau hessler
vielen dank ja frau rösler sie sind
professorin für philosophie an der
universität in amsterdam
wollten sie immer schon wieder so viel
werden ich hab erst noch andere studien
hinter mich gebracht muss ich sagen ist
aber schon sehr lange her in einem
früheren leben aber habe ich theologie
und deutsch studiert und habe dabei
gemerkt dass ich lieber philosophie
studieren und lieber so tief wie möglich
grabe und ja das war damals alles noch
ein bisschen einfacher da konnte man ein
bereich studium abschließen und dann mit
dem nächsten beginnen das habe ich
gemacht und ich gehe mal davon aus dass
sie das leben leben das sie leben wollen
wo haben sie das ja woran merkt man dass
das merkt man schon daran denke ich dass
man im prinzip keine großen sachen
verändern möchte dass man sich im
prinzip zu hause fühlt in dem leben das
man lebt das man im prinzip den eindruck
hat dass wenn man was ändern wollte dann
könnte man das auch ich sag immer im
prinzip weil das stimmt natürlich nicht
vollkommen und nicht immer und nicht
jeden tag und
stunde aber ja im prinzip lebe ich das
leben was ich leben will
das ist interessant insofern weil ich
gerade jetzt gedacht habe für mich zum
beispiel ist es nicht immer so klar das
leben das ich lebe wirklich genau das
ist was ich leben wir effektiv ich fühle
mich oft ambivalent oder hin- und
hergerissen ich mache meinen meine
arbeit sehr sehr gerne
ich bin gerne moderatorin ich stehe
immer noch mal gerne in der
öffentlichkeit ich spreche gerne hier
mit ihnen aber manchmal bin ich auch
sehr gerne alleine zu hause an meinem
schreibtisch und denke dass mich der
wissenschaft das wäre schon auch so eine
richtig schöne sache und diese
ambivalenz die gib mir mal so ein
bisschen das gefühl mich so genau zu
wissen was ich will ist das ein problem
ich glaube nicht dass das ein problem
ist ich glaube dass das teil der art und
weise ist wie wir leben und wir können
gar nicht anders als ohne diese
ambivalenzen leben problematisch wird es
erst wenn die ambivalenzen dazu führen
dass man eigentlich nicht mehr handeln
kann das heißt wenn sie zu hause am
schreibtisch sitzen und den eindruck
haben ich will eigentlich nicht ins
studio ich möchte eigentlich lieber
wissenschaftlerin werden
wissenschaftlerin werden ist aber nicht
so einfach
vielleicht sollte ich doch ins studio
und dann sind sie im globalisierten und
das ist natürlich ein problem
dann würde man sagen ambivalenzen
verhindern autonomie aber im prinzip ist
es glaube ich wirklich so dass
ambivalenzen so zu unserem alltag
gehören und wir so gelernt haben damit
umzugehen
das will ich auf die idee kommen würden
ein ambivalenz freies leben leben zu
können und es ist ja auch nicht auf die
idee kommen uns von diesen ambivalenzen
wirklich ja paralysieren oder oder lemm
zu lassen das geht ja häufig nicht um
diese ganz fundamentalen ambivalenzen
die sie gerade genannt haben sondern
meistens geht es um andere soll ich
jetzt heute abend wirklich noch ins kino
gehen ab wo ich echt schon so müde bin
und keine lust habe ja andererseits habe
ich versprochen und diese ambivalenzen
mit denen können wir gut umgehen und
noch vielleicht eine sache zu der frage
liebe ich das leben das ich leben will
einer der gründe warum der romane lesen
hat man in meiner generation ja noch
während des studiums das klingt zu blöd
aber es ist wirklich die die strecken
lesen heute weniger ich ja hier haben
einfach weniger zeit das ist einfach so
denn ja weil sie viel mehr mit internet
beschäftigt sind und so weiter und auch
diese lange spanne die es brauchte um zb
johns jahrestage zu lesen
das wird viel schwerer gemacht natürlich
gibt es noch viele studierende die die
viel lesen aber es wird viel schwerer
gemacht und damals hatten wir ja nicht
so viele ablenkungsmöglichkeiten aber
was ich sagen wollte ist dass wir romane
auch deswegen lesen oder filme schauen
deswegen weil wir uns gerne mit anderen
leben konfrontieren weil wir uns gerne
vorstellen wie es wäre so ein leben zu
leben und das reicht dann manchmal
vielleicht schon
und wenn die unzufriedenheit oder die
entfremdung vom eigenen leben zu groß
wird dann ändern die meisten menschen
und sonst gibt es wirklich ein problem
wird aus was wir selbstbestimmung nennen
können auf das gelungene leben gerät ins
wanken
sie haben ja in ihrem buch auch ganz
viele beispiel aus filmen und romanen
man merkt wie sie das material auch aus
dieser kann der sparte rausziehen und
mit der philosophie verknüpfen kann er
noch kurz bei der ambivalenz bleiben
man spricht ja viel oder war vielleicht
vor allem zwei jahren um stärker von der
generation web also dieser generation
die sich nicht festlegen mag die
eigentlich sagen wir mal die
unentschiedenheit fast schon zu ihrem
markenzeichen gemacht hat
man macht nicht wirklich termine sondern
sie es immer alles mal schauen mal
gucken komme ich heute nicht komm ich
morgen so mal vor sich hin leben kann
man auch entschieden unentschieden sein
ich glaube das ist ein anderes phänomen
ich glaube nicht dass das das typische
ambivalenz phänomen ist sondern ich
glaube dass das ehren und phänomen ist
der generellen unsicherheit oder
verunsicherungen vielleicht auch eher
ein problem das sich gar nicht mit
entscheidungen konfrontieren wollen die
ambivalente person die wir gerne
leiden sie weiß halt nur nicht was sie
tun soll aber diese generation das
vielleicht ist ja verunsichert in der
frage wie soll ich mich eigentlich was
ist entscheidung überhaupt was heißt
eigentlich festlegen
das ist eine andere form der
verunsicherung glaube ich als die der
ambivalenz das hat er was zu tun glaube
ich mit diesem mit der idee die habe
frankfurt in seinem buch entwickelt von
den konten von demjenigen der einfach
sich so unbestimmt durchs leben treiben
lässt und gar nicht weiß wie er oder sie
ihre freiheit leben soll weil sie gar
nicht weiß was es eigentlich bedeutet
darüber wirklich ernsthaft nachzudenken
was sie will und das finde ich
problematisch das ist natürlich keine
selbstbestimmung nun würde ich der
ganzen generation diese selbstbestimmung
nicht absprechen wollen man muss da
immer sehr genau schauen nach den
einzelfällen aber man muss auch schauen
wie die phänomene eigentlich
interpretiert werden müssen aber das
mittel schon heißen jetzt ja uns doch
jetzt so gesagt so ein wohnten so eine
figur die eben einfach vor sich hin lebt
auch nicht groß reflektiert was sie
macht die hatten probleme mit ihrer
selbstbestimmung genau war ja dass ich
ja erst mal interessant weil man sagen
würde die person die ihr leben plant die
gibt ja eigentlich frei hat ob sie nimmt
sich dinge vor und das leben wird
geplant damit eigentlich ein bisschen
unfreie aber im resultat werden sie doch
sagen wird das autonome und damit auch
frei ja eigentlich an dieser spruch wie
hier kommt natürlich ein bisschen darauf
an auch wie man die begriffe bestimmt
ich möchte das nicht einfach nur auf
technologische fragen reduzieren aber
frei zu sein heißt ja noch nicht
unbedingt auch zu wissen was man mit
dieser freiheit machen soll und
autonomie ist gerade dieses extra was
wir brauchen und was wir schätzen um mit
unserer freiheit auch wirklich frei
leben zu können und zur autonomie gehört
sicherlich so was wie darüber
nachzudenken was man möchte was man will
wie man leben will und auch darüber
nachzudenken als welche person will ich
leben wollen sie als jemand leben die in
erster linie wissenschaft macht und zu
hause ist und er dieses diese private
formen des lebens fehlt oder wollen sie
jemand sein die gerne in der
öffentlichkeit steht das sind ja
grundfragen und wir stellen die uns auch
auf mehr alltäglicher niveau und das ist
ein teil der autonomie dass wir uns
überlegen ja wer bin ich eigentlich wie
will ich leben und was ist wenn man
beide sind beides im sinne von frei sein
und autonom oder beide sehen ist
unsicher fühlen da spielt ja ja ich
würde sagen versuchen es gibt dieses
beispiel was ich im buch interpretiere
von dem roman von siri hustvedt die
gleißende welt wo die protagonistin die
hauptfigur halbiert werden
zugleich für minister künstlerin sein
möchte und die liebende ehefrau ihres
mannes der den kunstbetrieb genauso
organisiert das feministische künstlerin
eigentlich ausgeschlossen werden und ich
denke was sie regus fährt zeigt ist dass
es durchaus möglich ist zwischen zwei
identitäten zu switchen also pariert
werden ist manchmal die feministische
künstlerin sie trägt zwar den masken und
das ist alles ein bisschen komplizierter
die kulissen machen junge männer
sie lässt nicht ganz für sie machen
steht gemacht und licht genau sie
veröffentlicht und den armen von drei
verschiedenen jungen männern und das
heißt sie hat eigentlich genau das
gleiche problem wie sie gerade mit dem
wir legen auch wenn sie registriert ist
ein roman und sie will sich nicht
entscheiden
sie findet auch beide sorten das leben
ist beide identitäten attraktiv es ist
nicht so dass sie sich als frau iris
nicht besonders feministinnen mannes
unglücklich fühlt oder besonders
entfremdet sie kann darin aufgehen
genauso wie in der
identität der kriminalistischen
künstlerin und ich denke mir sowas es
möglich wir haben das in abgeschwächter
form leben wir das alle ich bin
natürlich im beruf jemand anders als zu
hause oder mit freunden oder wir haben
alle diese verschiedenen identitäten
zwischen den wir wechseln normalerweise
stehen die nicht so direkt in opposition
miteinander
aber das gehört auch zum leben dazu und
eigentlich kann man ja sagen es ist ein
riesen luxusproblem wir haben
unglaublich viele optionen und das macht
es auch wahnsinnig schwierig sie haben
vor die studierenden erwähnt die so viel
ablenkung haben aber eine schwierigkeit
ist tatsächlich auch dass viele menschen
ist schwierig finden zu wählen und sieht
die freiheit fast als geiseln finden nun
ist das ja kein neues phänomen im
engeren sinne also schon bei sören
kirkegaard findet man dass das freiheit
eigentlich eine aufgabe ist oder schon
poser 8
man muss ich dauernd entwerfen das macht
einen unglaublich müde ist auch eine
riesenverantwortung die auf uns lastet
und trotzdem scheint seine umwertung zu
geben und meine kollegin sportart hat im
vorfeld mit daniel hell gesprochen ein
psychiater der zur depression forscht
und daniel hell sagt in diesem interview
und dass man auf unserer webseite
nachlesen kann
er sagt da früher waren es vor allem
schuldgefühle die menschen gequält haben
weil sie gemerkt haben sie passen nicht
so recht zu den erwartungen die die
außenwelt an sie heran trägt und heute
sind es vor allem schamgefühle weil sie
den erwartungen nicht genügend die sitel
waren sich stellen und dann könnte man
ja sagen dann sind wir selber schuld
dass wir probleme haben weil sie einfach
zu hohe ideale haben stimmt das so hier
naja ich bin ja kein psychiaterin und
ich möchte auch nicht diese phänomene so
gerne katalogisieren also so beschreiben
als seien wir alle krank weil es gibt
natürlich bedingungen unter denen wir
krank werden können und
und auf eine weise schirm oder an und
selbstzweifeln die als unmöglich autonom
selbstbestimmt zu überlegen
aber ich weiß nicht ob diese generellen
analysen von ganzen generationen ob die
so wahnsinnig viel helfen um darüber
nachzudenken was es bedeutet ein
autonomes individuelles leben zu leben
noch mal eben zu dieser generation die
jetzt alle angeblich nicht mehr wissen
was sie wollen
es wird ja nicht nur schwieriger gemacht
weil abgelenkt werden sondern es wird
auch sehr viel schwieriger gemacht weil
es als ich angefangen habe zu studieren
da gab es so im prinzip fünf fächer
irgendwie literatur philosophie medizin
und jura so ungefähr
und heutzutage gibt es ich weiß nicht
ich glaube an meine 100 wahrscheinlich
150 verschiedene studiengänge
das heißt diese diversifizierung von
möglichkeiten
er führt auch dazu dass man ganz anders
darüber nachdenken muss was man
eigentlich wählen will und dazu kommt
dass es dieses gemütliche studium was
ich noch hatte sie vielleicht auch wo
man einfach eben viel gearbeitet und
viel gelernt hat heutzutage auch nicht
mehr so leicht möglich ist weil das
studium so viel kürzer dauert
und deswegen glaube ich ich weiß nicht
ob wir alle so viel höhere ideale haben
an denen wir scheitern so dass wir uns
wie gesagt ich kenne dieses werk nicht
ich habe auch noch nicht mal das
interview gelesen aber ich würde da erst
mal glaube ich die phänomene anders
interpretieren wollen aber trotzdem ist
es so sagen jetzt auch es gibt diese
unfassbar vielen optionen die wir haben
was tut denn eine selbst bestimmte
person angesichts dieser lage
sie könnte sich ja sagen ich entscheide
mich einfach blindlings für zwei drei
dinge und den rest ignoriere ich prüfe
die optionen gar nicht ist das ein ihrer
weg na ja das ist nicht so ein warmes
klima sorgen soll die akteure auch eine
gute alternative
ich glaube also erstens darf man ja
nicht vergessen personen werden
nicht einfach von einem von der tabula
rasa sie sind ja immer schon jemand
geworden
mit 17 18 mit einem bestimmten
hintergrund mit bestimmten ideen und
vorstellungen auch erfahrungen mit sich
selbst erfahrungen mit anderen und auf
dem hintergrund wählen sie und natürlich
ist es schwierig zu sagen
sie müssen alle möglichkeiten durchgehen
und reflektieren so funktioniert es ja
nicht funktioniert er auch so häufig
dass sich die optionen sozusagen die
passenden optionen anbieten ja dass die
nicht gerade dass sie sagen nimm mich
bitte weil ich passt zu dir aber doch so
dass bestimmte optionen auch gar nicht
angeschaut werden und ich glaube dass
die autonome die selbstständige die ich
würde auch sagen erwachsene person sich
darüber im klaren ist das ist ein
schwieriger prozess ist dieses wählen
und dieses sich entscheiden aber dass
die frage oder das problem dass man sich
grundsätzlich falsch entscheidet sich so
häufig entsteht das kann natürlich sein
wenn sie nach zehn jahren merken ich
will eigentlich so nicht leben ich will
eigentlich wirklich ich wünschte ich
hätte mir damals getraut medizin zu
studieren oder ich wünschte ich hätte
mir damals getraut grundschullehrerin zu
werden das es gibt aber trotzdem glaube
ich dass es möglich ist reflektiert
halbwegs reflektiert halbwegs vernünftig
mit diesen optionen umzugehen
es gibt ja auch das gegenbeispiel die
personen die genau wissen was sie wollen
und einen ganz konkreten lebensplan
haben also denken die an roger federer
bester tennisspieler der welt sage ich
jetzt auch schweizerin der hat ein
bestimmtes projekt in seinem leben der
hat das durchgezogen ist unglaublich gut
geworden aber da fragt man sich doch
dann auch ist diese person eigentlich
noch frei also kann die jetzt morgen
sorgen fertig mache ich alles nicht mehr
natürlich kann sie ein stück weit aber
wenn man doch so verwoben ist mit einem
einzigen projekt dann ist es auch schwer
sich wieder davon zu distanzieren
ich glaub ich was ich von roger federer
mitbekomme scheint er nicht sehr
unglücklich zu sein
mit mit seinem leben warum sollte man
sagen dass das keine erwachsene
vernünftige ich versuche die begriffe so
zu wählen dass man ja dass die nicht zu
spezifisch sind ja warum sollte das
keine solche wahl seien für federer
wenn er sich so obsessiv mit einem
projekt in die identifiziert ich finde
sowas ja immer bewundernswert muss ich
sagen weil auch die ganze
selbstdisziplin die dazu gehört ja und
diese idee die man von sich selber hat
ich möchte gerne ein wirklich guter
tennisspieler werden
ich finde nicht dass ist der freiheit
widerspricht zumal er nun gerade wie
gesagt ich hab jetzt bin kein bin kein
besonderes denn ich weiß nicht genau was
er so sagt in interviews aber er macht
nicht den eindruck er sei getrieben als
sei er von diesem projekt getrieben und
würde sich eigentlich gar nicht damit
identifizieren wollen ich denke immer
wenn personen obsessiv mit ihrer arbeit
oder mit ihren kindern sind oder umgehen
ist es eigentlich eher ein gutes zeichen
also wenn es nicht pathologisch ist ja
wenn es nicht wirklich eine krankheit
wird weil das bedeutet dass sie sich
wirklich damit identifizieren und dafür
auch bereit sind viel aufzugeben das ist
ja an sich nichts schlechtes
ihre idee ist ja im grunde genommen ein
leben ist dann ein gelungenes leben und
eben auch ein autonomes leben das gehört
für sich uns eng zusammen wenn wir uns
mit unserem leben eben identifizieren im
sinne von was ihr sagen das ist wirklich
mein eigenes leben
ich lebe mein eigenes leben in diesem
zusammenhang muss man doch aber auch
daran denken was ist ja sowas wie keine
ahnung schicksalsschläge geht zum
beispiel es gibt ja genau die gegen die
db pictet zb der immer betont hat
bedenke dass du nur schauspieler bist in
einem schauspiel bei denen das
spielleiter sozusagen die regeln besteht
er bestellt und diese vorstellung sich
zu sagen na ja so wirklich hab ich nicht
in der hand wie kriegen wir das zusammen
mit dem eigenen leben liegen
ich möchte gerne einen unterschied
machen zwischen dem selbstbestimmten
leben dem glücklichen leben und den
sinnvollen leben und ich glaube das was
sie ansprechen mit dem schicksal und den
schicksalsschlägen das bestimmt oder das
berührt vor allem die frage unseres
glücks weil ich glaube und ich versuche
das an beispielen zu zeigen im buch dass
wir sehr wohl sehr wohl in ein
sinnvolles leben leben können ohne dass
wir dabei glücklich sind federer zum
beispiel kann ja irgendwie ein
schicksalsschlag gehabt haben
ich möchte da jetzt nicht spekulieren
aber stellen wir uns vor irgendwie ein
besonders guter tennisspieler der auch
noch sehr glücklich ist mit seinem beruf
dessen mutter oder vater stirbt in der
sehr überraschenden situation dann kann
er sehr unglücklich sein aber er kann
trotzdem morgen oder übermorgen oder
vielleicht auch erst in einer woche
wieder zum training gehen
ich glaube das ist wichtig ist für uns
selbst aus der ersten person perspektive
und auch aus der perspektive der dritten
person zu unterscheiden
dass das selbstbestimmte leben sehr
fundamental zusammenhängt mit den
projekten mit dem beruf mit den
beziehungen und so weiter die wir leben
aber das zum glücklichen leben immer
noch etwas dazu kommt was wir nicht in
eigenen händen haben und dazu gehört es
schicksal und das gelungene leben ist
für mich ein leben in dem wir selbst
bestimmt unsere projekte leben die
sinnvoll sind und in dem wir dazu hier
noch glücklich sind dass er es ist das
gelungene leben nehmen wir zum beispiel
eine frau die fällt mir gerade ein
wie habt ihr kind verloren im vorjahr
bei den anschlag bei dem terroranschlag
und oder bei dem amoklauf und diese frau
hat eine organisation gegründet zur
prävention von amokläufen die frau tut
unglaublich viel gutes wir würden
wahrscheinlich von außen her sagen die
hat ein sinnvolles leben und trotzdem
werden sie gleich sagen in gewisser
hinsicht ist das leben ein unglückliches
leben weil diese frau hat ihr kind
verloren er furchtbar was kann sie tun
und dann trotzdem glücklich zu sein also
dass das klingt jetzt ja so was würden
die sorgen sein leben kann ich mich
nicht glücklich sein weil was
furchtbares passiert ist aber viele
würden doch auch sagen auch das glück
haben die ein stück weit in den händen
ja da bin ich skeptisch aber ich möchte
doch eben noch mal schnell eine
bemerkung ein film darüber was die
philosophie macht die philosophie ist
nicht als philosophie lebensberaterin
ich kann jetzt nicht zu dieser frau
gehen und sagen als philosophien würde
ich ihnen sagen sie sollten das sind das
versuchen damit ihr leben leben
glücklicher ist zumal ich gar nicht weiß
ob sie nicht vielleicht ein glückliches
leben hat eben der punkt um den es hier
geht ist zu sagen
diese frau hat ihr leben offenbar grund
sich grundlegend verändert und hat sich
der dieser stiftung oder diese
organisation verschrieben versucht also
auf eine wirklich von außen gesehen
extrem konstruktive weise mit dem
verlust des kindes umzugehen
und deswegen ist bestimmt aus der ersten
person perspektive und auch aus unserer
perspektive der dritten person ihr leben
sinnvoll
wir finden das eine gute sache die frage
des glücks ist ja eine wo wir sagen
würden ja natürlich manchmal machen uns
diese diese projekte auch glücklich aber
glück ist immer was was sozusagen denn
das mit einem anderen philosophen jersey
fr sa ist der huckepack auf anderen
motiven reist ich mach eigentlich
beinahe nie irgendwas nur deswegen weil
ich denke so werde ich glücklich sondern
ich mache das was ich interessant finde
was ich spannend finde was ich wichtig
finde so wie diese frau von der sie
geredet haben und dabei gehe ich
natürlich davon aus dass wir nicht das
kann und wenn es mir gelingt dass ich
dann auch glücklich werde
das muss aber nicht so sein vielleicht
interessiert mich weil sie das ja zu
unterschieden haben glückliches leben
sinnvolles leben ein autonomes leben und
so weiter was ist denn zb mit dem
berühmten grashorn zähler der kommt auch
vor in ihrem buch das ist ein beispiel
von john roos den berühmten
gerechtigkeit theoretiker der bringt
dieses beispiel von einem mann der hätte
ein berühmter mathematik-professor
werden können
stattdessen entscheidet er sich grashorn
zähler zu werden er setzt sich aus auf
dem boden und zählt die grashalme immer
in bestimmten abgesteckten gebieten
und er sagt aber auch für ihn sei das
sinnvoll was er da macht von außen
betrachtet denkt man was ist das für
eine schwachsinnige aufgabe graf fahne
zu zählen und die philosophie hat
richtig den kopf über dieses beispiel
was ist genau das problem was antworten
sie naja das ist glaube ich ein kleines
bisschen anders
konstruiert weil diese person tagsüber
mathematiker ist und nach der arbeit
grashalme zählt es ist nicht ganz so
absurd das ist bleibt immer noch relativ
absurd
ja die leute die das diskutieren die
sind meistens der meinung dass das
bizarre idee des sinnvollen lebens ist
und ich versuche da ich versuche diesen
grasheim zähler zu verteidigen weil ich
glaube dass es schwierig ist ganz genau
dran zu ziehen zwischen dem was wir in
unserer gesellschaft noch für sinnvoll
halten und dem was wirklich sinnlos ist
in einem objektiven sind man kann sagen
na ja die idee dass man hier seine
kartographie macht ja der sitzt im
college und hat diese college quadrate
ja und irgendwann denkt er bin ich
soweit wirklich die genaue karte
kartographie meines college rasens geben
ja ich denke dann immer jammern aber die
wachsen doch die ganze zeit also ich
habe er solche probleme damit alles zu
sagen das ist ein sinnloses unterfangen
ist und ich glaube man sollte vorsichtig
sein solche fälle so schnell zu
katalogisieren wieder zu sagen ja der
spinnt doch einfach man kann sich ja mit
ihm unterhalten gegebenenfalls man kann
ihn fragen ok warum machst du das und ja
ich habe immer schon zahlen interessant
gefunden keine ahnung was da ja nur
darauf finde ich wusste nicht weiter aus
ich glaube bevor man solche projekte so
abqualifiziert und dann natürlich auch
noch eine allgemeine theorie darauf baut
nämlich hier sehen wir ein sinnloses
projekt und deswegen ist kann man
natürlich irgendwie was allgemeine sagen
über den sinn des lebens
das finde ich problematisch ist ja
insgesamt so dass ihr buch ein sehr
freiheitlichen gestus haut ist ein sehr
liberales buch das heißt es geht ihnen
auch darum immer wieder zu sagen wir
brauchen hier keine paternalistische
vorstellung dessen was eigentlich ein
autonomes leben ausmacht was ein
geglücktes leben ausmacht das ein
sinnvolles leben ausmacht sondern es
geht darum aufzuzeigen dass ihnen das
eigene leben aus eigenes leben zu
empfinden für unterschiedliche menschen
ganz unterschiedliches heißen kann
und ich würde gerne mit ihnen deswegen
mal versuchen so ein bisschen die
grenzen auszuloten wie weit können wir
da gehen und ein beispiel was viele
menschen bringen wenn sie sagen ja aber
das doch
fertig das kann doch niemand wirklich
selbst bestimmt werden wollen wäre so
etwas wie sklaverei oder auch sechs
arbeit das ist immer wieder so ein
beispiel was leute in dringend eine
schwarze zum beispiel würde sagen
niemand keine frau wird wirklich
selbstbestimmt prostituierte und habe
ich ein beispiel gefunden von eos ist
sexarbeiterin und sie spricht im to talk
darüber dass sie durchaus selbstbewusst
und selbstbestimmt sexarbeiterin
geworden ist er stürmt die sind
überhaupt nicht dumme es gibt auch der
wochenabschluss allen oder immer noch
studieren sind und einfach mit bekannte
zu verdienen
ich kann keinen job gefunden er callt
und wann ist mit sechs mann verbinde ich
sehr gern mag
wieso nicht es gibt dir was hat der
familie annette erzählt wie sich
charmant aber ich selber schon vor
wochen gesagt ich bin ehrlich zu jedem
will sich doppel aber das macht ein
psychisch kranker mann hat meine tochter
spricht und die juden das ist normal
will dass wir auch ich wenn ich als kind
hätte ich würde alles reagieren
aber sie hat mir gesagt egal was ich
hoffe ich bin immer noch nicht was ich
mir wünsche ist der situation
akzeptieren wie jeder andere als ist
vielleicht speziell ja aber das heißt ja
dass man andere menschen sind und wann
etwas unklares bevölkerung thailand mit
vw und verein geht ist diese frau selbst
bestimmt sie weckt absolut den eindruck
als ob sie selbst bestimmte ja ich
glaube man muss hier aufpassen natürlich
würde ich jetzt auch nicht die
gegenposition vertreten wollen gegen
alice schwarzer oder steht ja immer
wieder solche bewegungen zum
prostitution generell zu verbieten ich
würde auch nicht sagen position ist
immer selbst bestimmt es gibt natürlich
schreckliche zustände für prostituierte
wenn sie abhängig sind von einem
zuhälter wenn sie gezwungen werden in
die prostitution
das ist gar keine frage aber es gibt ja
schon seit jahrzehnten mittlerweile eine
prostituierten bewegung die sagt wir
wollen prostituierte sein und wir wollen
bedingungen haben wir wollen zum
beispiel die krankenversicherungen wir
wollen wohnraum der nicht irgendwie
isoliert ist wo wir gefahr laufen mit
gewalt konfrontiert zu werden
all dies ist würde ja bedingungen
schaffen unter denen prostituierte
tatsächlich selbst bestimmt ihr leben
leben und ich muss sagen ich finde diese
junge frau wirklich sehr beeindruckend
obwohl ich mir auch vorstellen kann wie
die mutter reagierte ich werde auch
nicht so begeistert wenn meine tochter
gerne prostituierte werden wollen würde
und man muss natürlich auch genau gucken
hatte sie wirklich andere möglichkeiten
unter welchen bedingungen hat sie sich
entschieden
was was macht ihre identität aus aber
ich finde es ich finde es vollkommen
paternalistisch und irgendwie auch
arrogant zu sagen na ja hier haben wir
doch ein beispiel von einer
unterdrückten nicht selbst bestimmten
prostituierten
ich glaube wirklich dass man gerade bei
der prostitution beide sehen muss die
die gewalttätigen verhältnisse unter den
prostituierten häufig arbeiten müssen
und die verhältnisse die es ihnen
ermöglicht ja auf eine schnelle weise
geld zu verdienen zum beispiel warum
diskutieren eigentlich so viele
beispiele über die grenzen der
selbstbestimmung am körper der frau sie
mir vor allem solche beispiele ein
also wie eben sexarbeit auch pornografie
diskutieren über die frauen nicht über
die männer aber auch leihmutterschaft so
leicht bin da geht es sehr schnell
darunter sagt keine frau würde das je
wählen selbst bestimmt warum geht es
darum den körper der frau
ja weil wir eben immer noch ein
patriarchat leben
das ist einfach so und ich glaube dass
theorien die dies kritisieren häufig
nicht beachten dass wir zugleich immer
auch die gesellschaftlichen bedingungen
kritisieren müssen unter denen diese
probleme entstehen oder unter denen auch
die theorien selbst gemacht werden ja
leihmutterschaft finde ich ja wie soll
ich sagen finde ich in ethisch wirklich
interessantes problem aber nicht
unbedingt nur eins wo es eine eindeutige
oder irgendwie prima fazit sehr
plausible feministische positionen gibt
ich glaube da kann man auch als
feministin wirklich beide positionen
dafür und dagegen gut dafür gut
argumentieren das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt im fall der prostitution auch
wenn ich jetzt mir wahrscheinlich den
ärger von alles schweizer an den hals
ole finde ich das eigentlich anders weil
es eben wirklich eine prostituierten
bewegung gibt die sehr plausibel
argumentiert und zwar schon lange gibt
dass sie unter anderen bedingungen
arbeiten wollen unter möglichst guten
arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten wollen aber
dass sie sich nicht den job verbieten
lassen wollen und haben sie vorher ja
gesagt diese frau die hätte auf jeden
fall andere wahlmöglichkeiten haben also
das ist sozusagen eine bedingung dass
wir sagen eine person ist nicht frei
wenn sie gezwungen wird in etwas und sie
keine auswahl hand und gibt natürlich
viele leute die sagen na ja das haben
wir ja nie also wollen wir wirklich den
bürojob machen denn wir machen wollen
wir wirklich keine ahnung morgens um
sieben aufstehen und die kinder parat zu
machen es gibt ja viele dinge die wir
manchmal auch aus nicht so frei
gewählten finden und nicht alle leute
haben alternative ja und völlig richtig
es hat auch keinen sinn so zu tun als
würden wir alle in dieser privilegierten
position leben und gegen bestimmte dinge
entscheiden zu können und wirklich nur
das zu tun was uns lieb ist auch in
meinem beruf den ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal halbwegs autonom gewählt
habe
gibt es unheimlich viele sachen die ich
vollkommen hätte
muss die ganze bürokratie zum beispiel
die zu meinem beruf mittlerweile dazu
gehört aber ich glaube das sind zwei
verschiedene sachen das eine ist wenn
wir uns im prinzip für einen beruf
entschieden haben finden wir den immer
noch gut finden wir dieses leben immer
noch gut und das andere ist unter
welchen bedingungen haben wir uns dann
entschieden was bedeutet eigentlich
diese entscheidung denn je in der
position zu sagen ich bin frei zwischen
a b und c zu wählen oder werde ich immer
irgendwie in bestimmte rollen in
bestimmte lebensmuster undsoweiter
gedrängt und ja ich glaube beides ist
wahr wir werden immer gedrängt durch
strukturen zb patriarchale strukturen
die sich auch in den letzten 30 jahren
durchaus verändert und verbessert haben
junge mädchen haben heute mehr
möglichkeiten einen eigenen willen zu
entwickeln muss ich sagen und dann auch
eine eigene wahl zu begründen
als noch vor 30 jahren aber natürlich
werden wir immer aufgrund der herkunft
aufgrund der beziehungen in denen wir
leben auch aufgrund der sozialen milieus
natürlich in bestimmte richtungen
gedrängt und ich glaube man muss hier
wieder in unterschichten machen
einmal ist es so dass das soziale milieu
also leute in das ist eigentlich ein
euphemismus eigentlich ein schönes wort
für eine sehr kritikwürdige sache leute
in armen verhältnissen haben sehr viel
weniger wahl und sehr viel weniger die
möglichkeit interessante option zu
wählen als leute in guten verhältnissen
dass das eine das heißt das sind
gesellschaftliche strukturen die auch
immer mit bestimmen wie wir leben sollen
wie wir leben wollen und die man auch
kritisieren muss eine extrem in
egalitäre gesellschaft muss genau
deswegen kritisiert werden weil große
teile der bevölkerung oder der der
person um die es uns geht sich eben
nicht frei und autonom entscheiden
können was ihr leben betrifft das ist
das eine aber das andere ist es dieses
was ich versuche mit eines murdoch zum
beispiel zu zeigen dass wir immer
abhängig sind in beziehungen zu eltern
zu kindern zu freunden und so weiter das
betrifft jeden das kann auch
haben der oder die sehr reich ist und
sehr gut ihr leben vor augen hat es gibt
diese beiden sorten abhängigkeit ja zu
beiden dingen habe ich 1000 fragen da
gehen wir mit aris murdoch die haben
auch die ein zitat auf ihrem buch
wunderschönes die tat von aris murdoch
einer britischen philosophen der
britisch irische sie sagt man schaut
nicht einfach hin und welt etwas
man steigt immer schon bis zum hals in
seinem leben und in diesem buch setzen
sie sich auch damit auseinander was ist
eigentlich heißt autonomie beziehungs
basiert zu denken es gibt diese große
kritik auch an der autonomie leute die
sagen philosophin den vor allem die
sagen hört mal auf damit immer autonomie
sich so vorzustellen als wären die pilze
wie thomas hobbes sich das vorgestellt
hat
pilze aus dem boden sprießen sondern wir
sind immer schon in geweben miteinander
verbunden
eigentlich lustig pilze sind ja die zone
also eigentlich hatte hawks vielleicht
doch recht
aber davon abgesehen diese idee dass wir
in familiengeführten zum beispiel leben
und eigentlich gar nicht wirklich so
ganz von vorne anfangen
da scheint ja wirklich eine gewisse
spannung zu bestehen man könnte ja
eigentlich sogar sagen zum glück ist das
so weil sonst wäre es ja noch
schwieriger zum glück haben jedoch
menschen die uns halt geben und uns
vielleicht aus kehrseite des holz auch
einschränken
ganz genau nein absolut das wird ja in
der literatur heutzutage in der
philosophische literatur relationale
autonomie genannt also autonomie die
immer schon in beziehung verankert ist
und sich auch so begreift und dieses
alte bild von autonomie des einsamen
cowboys der durch die wüste leitet das
ist sozusagen so autonom wollen wir alle
sein
das stimmt ja schon lange nicht mehr das
ist von feministinnen schon in den 60er
70er jahren kritisiert worden und von
manchen feministinnen ist es so
kritisiert fandest du sagen ja mit dem
begriff können wir einfach gar nichts
mehr anfangen
lasst uns den begriff vergessen lasst
uns irgendwie sowas über sowas reden wie
es objekt werden und so weiter ich
glaube das ist falsch ich glaube der
begriff mit dem begriff können wir noch
ganz viel machen und den können wir auch
sehr kritisch einsetzen und man muss in
der tat
so lernen wir eigentlich autonom zu sein
in beziehung und man muss genau sehen
dass wir autonomie immer leben in
beziehung wir sind ja nicht wir ziehen
uns nicht in unser einsames kämmerlein
zurück oder reiten in die wüste wenn wir
überlegen wollen wie wir leben sondern
wir diskutieren mit anderen wir sind
immer schon dialogisch konstituiert und
und versuchen unser leben mit anderen
und deren bedürfnissen und deren ideen
gemeinsam zu leben
und doch muss man wieder sagen diese
beziehung haben das haben sie auch
gerade genannt können einen
doppelcharakter haben diese
janusköpfigkeit der beziehung dass sie
nämlich uns ermöglichen autonom zu leben
und dass sie zugleich verhindern können
dass personen ihre eigenen ideen von
autonomie entwickeln und mit dieser
janusköpfigkeit umzugehen auch das ist
teil des gelungenen lebens denke ich
vielleicht noch einmal ein beispiel
nämlich vor thema fátima treten kopf
durch und auch das kopftuch ist ja teil
einer tradition einer kultur zum teil
auch einfach eine familiengeschichte man
hat das in dieser familie immer schon so
gemacht und von außen betrachtet gibt es
wiederum viele die sagen naja kopftuch
tragen das ist nicht autonom fatima hat
eine andere position schauen wir uns das
an
die häufigste von hotel wo man immer
wieder höre ich das unglück und das will
man junge zuschauer weil jetzt nicht da
vor der kamera es geht die turner
kulturelle krise wo meine fehler werde
religion sowie religion geht sondern
über das konto
ja was ist mit dieser frau autonom ja
ich finde auch wieder wie diese andere
junge frau sie kommen also sie
vermittelt den eindruck wirklich
nachgedacht zu haben darüber wie sie
leben will
vor allem in dieser stelle wo sie sagt
ja manchmal möchte ich mir das kopftuch
vom kopf reißen aber dann denke ich doch
ich möchte sie behalten das ist ja so
eine stelle von ambivalenz und sich
überlegen will man dieses eigentlich
wirklich und ich finde sie sehr
überzeugend und das passt natürlich auch
zu meiner theorie weil ich finde es
vollkommen absurd das kopftuch verbieten
zu wollen weil das angeblich frauen
unterdrückt oder weil es anzeichen von
frauenunterdrückung ist und weil es so
eine religion gehört die als religionen
frauen immer unterdrückt das finde ich
absurd es hat jetzt gerade in
deutschland so eine diskussion gegeben
von terroropfern die vorgeschlagen haben
und auch verabschiedet haben
das kopftuch für mädchen zu verbieten
weil mädchen damit konditioniert würden
in ein bestimmtes leben und dann mit 18
oder sogar nicht mehr selber entscheiden
können wollen sie das kopftuch tragen
oder nicht
und das finde ich finde es absurd muss
ich sagen weil wir erstens deswegen weil
wir natürlich unsere kinder immer auch
konditionieren
ich würde ungern das wort benutzen
kommissionieren ich würde mal sagen wir
versuchen mit guten grünen noch schöner
wir versuchen natürlich zu überzeugen
und nicht zu konditionieren
aber ich habe zum beispiel einen
mitarbeiter der unter wirklich
wahnsinnig from protestantischen
verhältnissen aufgewachsen ist er hat
jahre gebraucht um sich davon zu lösen
aber es gab natürlich auch möglichkeiten
so und so über das leben nachzudenken
das heißt es betrifft
der punkt der erste punkte nicht machen
möchte ist das betrifft ja nicht nur das
kopftuch sondern es betrifft immer die
frage wie gehen wir mit unseren kindern
um und dann ist die zweite frage wie
verhalten wir uns gegenüber erwachsenen
frauen die das kopftuch tragen und da
würde ich sagen wir gehen immer erst mal
davon aus dass sie das selbst wollen
das ist auch muss ich sagen in den
niederlanden doch sehr
verbreiteter als wahrscheinlich in der
schweiz oder in deutschland
aber diese diskussion gibt es natürlich
immer wieder auch von feministinnen und
um nochmal zurückzukommen auf diese idee
dass wir immer schon in familien geboren
werden und aufgezogen werden und
konditioniert werden
wir werden natürlich in gewisser weise
konditioniert und sie haben alle unsere
neurosen aufgrund der verhältnisse in
denen wir groß geworden sind
aber wenn die familie halbwegs gut
funktioniert hat dann zeigt sie den
jungen leuten auch guck mal du bist auto
nun du kannst dich im prinzip auch von
werten die wir wertvoll finden
verabschieden
deswegen vielleicht noch ein satz dazu
das ist nicht nur die familie ist
sondern auch die schule hat ja eine ganz
wichtige funktion den kindern
beizubringen dass sie in unseren
halbwegs liberal demokratischen
verhältnissen selber bestimmen können
wie sie leben und die junge frau kann
auch wenn sie bildes kopftuch abziehen
aber sie möchte ja offenbar nicht sie
möchte sich identifizieren mit denen
werten traditionen und der kultur aus
der sie kommt und werde bestimmt auch
neu interpretieren was ich auch schön
finde ich glaube das kann jetzt gar
nicht in dem film des in dem etwas
längeren stück wo sie sagt ich möchte
die demokratie in der schweiz mit formen
und das finde ich großartig ja das heißt
ja sie interpretiert auch was es
eigentlich heißt ein kopftuch zu tragen
wenn ich ihnen zuhöre dann kriege ich
wirklich den eindruck es geht eigentlich
darum zu verstehen wir sind keine pilze
sondern wir sind verwoben in unserer
geschichte
das heißt nicht alles wählen wir
sozusagen von grund auf aber es geht
immer darum sich immer wieder zu
vergewissern stecke ich in dem leben das
ich eigentlich neben will kann ich das
bejahen was ich so grundsätzlich tue ja
im prinzip ja aber was sich auf versuche
deutlich zu machen einem buch ist dass
das keine kommunistische oder
komische idee der einheit des lebens und
der person ist oder auch nicht zu sein
braucht weil wir eben häufig auch von
verschiedenen kontexten in unserem
eigenen leben entfremdet sind das heißt
es ist doch wie soll ich sagen eine
ambivalente einheit oder auch eine
fragile einheit und manchmal eine
fragmentierte einheit
wenn wir hinter den projekten stehen die
wir uns in unserem leben leben wir sind
häufig auch von arbeitsbedingungen zb
entfremdet ja was sie vorhin schon
gesagt haben ja also ich häufig
identifiziere ich mich nicht mit der
arbeit wir sind auch von unseren
beziehungen häufig entfremdet sogar von
unseren kindern meint ja denke mir ja
muss das jetzt sein und ist es wirklich
so richtig und ja die kunden wie gehen
wir damit um war so ein anderes beispiel
was vielleicht noch schlager ist wir
sind doch oft auch entfremdet von
unseren konsum entscheidend
sie wissen doch alle dass wir sehr viel
mehr kaufen was wir brauchen und wir
wissen sogar das im artikel kaufen die
eine milch kaufen wollen
aber es gibt einen im moment ein gutes
gefühl oder man hat den eindruck man
braucht das jetzt einfach weil alle
haben das oder man sieht nicht schlecht
aus aber nicht wieder neue klamotten
trägt oder wenn man nicht so oft zum
friseur geht oder nicht so und so oft
fitness training macht dann sieht man
nicht entsprechend aus also sollte man
was tun wenn man im stillen kämmerchen
noch denkt denkt man eigentlich hätte
man besseres zu tun
wie genau gehen wir damit um wenn und
schon dieses gefühl dass der
fremdbestimmung der entfremdung ist ja
kein schönes wissen ich glaube
fremdbestimmung muss nicht unbedingt
dasselbe sein wie entfremdung ja ich
kann mich ja zum beispiel entschieden
haben
bestimmten stadt zu leben und merke aber
dass wir diese stadt sehr fremd ist dass
ich eigentlich das leben hier nicht ab
genau dass ich mich getäuscht habe
trotzdem kann ich bleiben auch unter der
bedingung dass ich eben mich in dieser
stadt nicht völlig glücklich und eins
mit mir selber fühle aber ich kann auch
versuchen daran etwas zu ändern
mit dem fremdbestimmten ich denke auch
dabei arbeitsbedingungen zum beispiel
muss man einerseits sagen ja damit
müssen wir laden zu leben
arbeit ist immer auch in gewisser weise
brand bestimmt das ist die eine seite
die andere seite ist dass genau diese
aspekte die sie gerade genannt haben
konsumgesellschaft kapitalistische
gesellschaft und so weiter in vielen
hinsichten ja das autonome leben auch
verhindern dass heißt wir müssen genau
diese strukturen auch immer kritisieren
ich versuche das in meinem buch dachte
ich dass ich zeige dass bestimmte
strukturen in unserer gesellschaft dazu
führen dass wir immer schon unsere
präferenzen das was wir wollen unsere
wünsche unsere vorstellungen anpassen
adaptieren ja dass wir also früher war
das beispiel immer das kleine mädchen
nur krankenschwester werden wollen und
keine arzt das stimmt irgendwie nicht
mehr so ganz statistisch gesehen aber
das ist sozusagen die grundlegende idee
wir passen unsere präferenzen an an die
gesellschaft in der wir leben
das konsumverhalten betreffend was darf
eine frau darf die ganz arbeiten wenn
die kinder noch klein sind und das heißt
wir müssen wenn wir eine plausible
autonomie theorie entwarfen müssen wir
zugleich eine kritische
gesellschaftstheorie entwerfen die sagt
hier sind strukturen die verhindern dass
er ein gutes gelungenes glückliches
selbstbestimmtes leben leben
das leuchtet mir komplett ein
gleichzeitig denke ich dann natürlich
auch ja und wo sind dann die grenzen
also gewiss die lebensform da würde ich
wahrscheinlich wirklich sagen allein ist
und deswegen weil sie die
wahlmöglichkeiten so ungleich verteilen
aus einem sexistischen gesellschaft oder
eine rassistische gesellschaft verteilt
wahlmöglichkeiten einfach ungleichen das
ist einfach scheint ungerecht das kann
man kritisieren aber jetzt bei der
die touristischen gesellschaft da kann
man sagen na ja das haben sich auch was
damit zu tun dass diejenigen die
vermögen sind da stärker mitmachen
können wie diejenigen die nicht
vermögend sind aber wenn wir das mal
noch beiseite lassen würden in einer
relativ reiche gesellschaft wo man den
leuten vorgaukelt du brauchst das alles
was genau können wir daran eigentlich
dann noch kritisieren
warum der kapitalismus hier relevant ist
ich glaube ich einfach daran dass der
kapitalismus wie wir ihn kennen
für extreme ungleichheit besorgt und für
extreme differenzen im machtverhältnis
von von menschen also ungleichheit und
macht sind begriffe die wir verwenden
müssen um bestimmte gesellschaftliche
strukturen zu kritisieren und ich finde
das nicht so schwierig ich meine es ist
immer schwierig gesellschaftliche
strukturen zu kritisieren weil man ja
immer schon drin hängt in der
gesellschaft und mir aus kann und sagen
guck mal von dieser perspektive aus ist
die gesellschaft unterricht man muss es
immer schon aus der gesellschaft heraus
machen und man muss zeigen in welcher
weise diese gesellschaftlichen
strukturen ihrer autonomie die autonomie
von uns allen
behindert und wie gesagt wir müssen
dürfen nicht vergessen dass diese
strukturen auch autonomie ermöglichen
das ist eben gerade diese diese
janusköpfigkeit dieses fatale werden
gehen wir noch mal zurück zum
persönlichen grenzen der
selbstbestimmung die haben jetzt schon
ein paar mal über aris murdoch
gesprochen eine philosophie die wir
beide sehr schwere und ja natürlich das
ist richtig die romanischen dank nicht
sogar fast wichtiger wir beide
philosophie ist auch ganz wunderbar und
einiger sowie in den listen vielleicht
macht man in vergessenheit gerät sie
wurde aber wieder sozusagen noch einmal
neu belebt durch die verfilmung des
buches von john dalli
es heißt das buch und ist sozusagen die
geschichte von eines mörders und warum
die frau so unfassbar interessant ist
die schriftstellerin und philosophin
sehr interessant aber interessant ist
auch dass sie an alzheimer erkrankte und
in dieser krankheit unglaublich abhängig
wurde von ihrem ehemann von diesem john
dalli der dann dieses buch über sie
geschrieben hat und in der verfilmung
ist das unglaublich ergreifend diese
wahnsinnig kluge frau die nahrung nach
ihr selbst eigentlich verliert und das
ist ja auch so eine grenze der
selbstbestimmung oder der autor
eine grenze die immer mehr menschen auch
an tangiert weil demenz erkrankungen out
erkrankungen zunehmen kann man denn noch
selbstbestimmt sein in einer solchen
erkrankung sicherlich nicht
sicherlich nicht weil schon deswegen
nicht weil wenn die demenz weit
fortgeschritten ist die person ja gar
keinen selbst begriff mehr hat und auch
zum beispiel keine zeitliche kein
zeitliches bewusstsein mehr
gestern wollte ich das heute will ich
das das kann man bestimmt nicht und man
kann dann in der philosophie werden dann
gerade in der medizinischen ethik
theorien entwickelt von assistierter
autonomie dh im prozess der das
dementieren
versucht man andere personen so zu
betreffen so mit einzubeziehen dass die
gleitende person selber ihre autonomie
nach und nach abgeben kann an jemanden
anders in alves murdochs fall war dass
ich würde sagen fatalerweise aber ich
stehe da relativ allein john bayley
erinnert hat ein buch von seiner
perspektive aus über das leben von als
mörder geschrieben hat also ob das leben
von eines mörders wirklich so wie soll
ich sagen sich aus der ersten person
perspektive von ihr selber auch so
dargestellt hätte wollen wir mal hoffen
lasse und in der tat bei ihr ist es
hochinteressant zu sehen
es ist ja schon also manche leute wird
ob jemand die literaturwissenschaftler
interpretieren die letzten romane von
ihr schon so dass man nachweisen kann in
der wortwahl und so weiter dass sie
dement geworden ist aber in der demenz
wie soll ich sagen sind wir uns alle
gleich
da ist alles murdoch nicht interessanter
oder selbstbestimmter als irgendjemand
anders und was ich auch sehr rührend
fand ist wie sie offenbar die
teletubbies einer der spannendsten das
ist gar nicht gut aus
denn genau das war eine zeitlang in
großer erinnern
bei kindern natürlich ist eine wirklich
in der sendung eine serie war das oder
eine sende und weiß gar nicht ob man
sehr jährigen kann für sehr kleine
kinder und das hatte was unheimlich
hören dass aber das hat bei jedem
menschen was rühren dass da brauche ich
keine als mörder zu sein um sozusagen
die die rührung zu provozieren
den leuten die sehen wie jemand die mal
ganz gut und und und auch glücklich und
selbstbestimmt gelebt hat wie sie in der
in der demenz landet aber ein knackpunkt
den iran hab da haben und die glauben
über den müssen wir sprechen ist das
wenn man ihr buch liest autonomie
einfach über das gelungene leben wo man
in märkt autonomie ist ganz wichtig für
ein gelungenes leben dass man sich dann
fragt hat denn eine demente person kein
gelungenes leben näher wunderbare frage
ich würde sagen gelungen indem sehen wie
ich das leben als gelungen beschreibe
nämlich als sinnvoll und glücklich ein
solches gelungenes leben hat sie nicht
sie können ein sehr gutes leben haben
sie kann auch ein sehr glückliches leben
haben häufig ist es also dass demente
personen sehr glücklich sind häufig dann
auch wieder nicht aber weil es eben
diese form von demenz gibt wo man sehr
hadert mit sich selber und der umwelt
aber das gelungene leben ist für mich
geknüpft an die frage der
selbstbestimmung auch kleine kinder zum
beispiel richtig kleine kinder können
kein gelungenes leben haben
die haben natürlich ein gutes leben
haben hoffentlich ein glückliches leben
aber man kann nicht sagen dass sie
selbst bestimmt sind weil sie hat so
eine idee von selbstbestimmung erst
entwickeln müssen und meistens weiß
nicht kommt wahrscheinlich auf die
persönlichkeit an jedenfalls spätestens
in der pubertät die idee entwickeln ich
will mein eigenes leben leben
aber deswegen kann man doch bei kleinen
kindern sagen es ist ein gutes leben es
ist ein glückliches leben
aber es ist nicht selbstbestimmt und das
ist deswegen auch nicht sinnvoll für das
kind selbst natürlich für uns kann das
leben des kindes sehr sinnvoll sein
dann auch für uns sehr sinnvoll sein die
demente mutter oder die elemente
großmutter werden zu versorgen
ich glaube ganz wichtig ist in diesem
moment dass sie nicht sagen oder damit
nicht sagen wollen dass man diese
lebensformen irgendwie abwerten wird das
ist ja dann sehr anschluss in die leute
ziel dass sie sagen na ja wenn das kein
gelungenes leben ist weil sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wertvoll es
ist ja nicht die meinung die sie
vertreten mir überhaupt nicht überhaupt
nicht im gegenteil ich sag ja gerade ein
glückliches leben kann man als demente
personen wunderbar haben
ob ich das wollen würde wie so wie ich
mich jetzt schüler ob ich dement werden
wollen würde
auch wenn es nicht glücklicher demenz
ist ist eine ganz andere frage und auch
eine frage in der keine wertung
drinsteckt über testamente leben da
genau da glaube ich kommt noch einmal
ein knackpunkt wolfgang herrndorf auch
in zitieren sie arbeiten struktur sein
wunderbares blog tagebuch wolfgang
herrndorf der deutsche autor der sich
das leben genommen hat er hat einen
tumor sehr aggressiv fortschreiten der
hat über sein leiden und über seine
krankheit geschrieben und er sagt an
einer stelle das zitieren sie ich muss
wissen dass sich herr im eigenen haus
bin weiter nichts und für ihn ist diese
sehnsucht eben noch ein gelungenes leben
zu haben eine autonomes leben auch
selbstbestimmung bis in den tod als er
hat sich in entscheidungen dann das
leben genommen
ist das für sie auch so wenn sie sagen
das gehört dazu die möglichkeit haben
die ja das gehört sicher dazu sicher bei
der idee wenn man wenn man leidet und
wenn man sieht dass man irgendwann einer
situation landen wird in der man
überhaupt gar nicht mehr auch mit
anderen kommunizieren kann
wollen sie jetzt eine moralische
bewertung der selbstmord prima also ich
finde da muss man immer gucken nach den
umständen ob man nicht irgendwie ob
andere leute nicht auch das hätten
verhindern können
aber natürlich darf sich eine kranke
person wenn sie das noch keine hand auf
das gemacht hat umbringen wir würden das
nicht moralisch kritisieren ich würde
das nicht mehr alles kritisieren bei
handorf das interessante ist und das
finde ich auch so schön an diesem zitat
ich muss herr im eigenen haus sein das
ist ja einen verweis nehme ich mal an
ein impliziter verweis nach freud
doch gesagt hat wir sind eigentlich
nicht mehr herr im eigenen haus ich weiß
nicht ob man das bei herrndorf mit
denken sollte ich würde das gern wir
denken weil er natürlich auch ringt um
die selbstbestimmung das ist das ist
auch das schöne an diesem buch er will
immer selbst bestimmt seien und auch
ganz unabhängig von seiner krankheit
denkt er immer wieder darüber nach was
heißt eigentlich selbstbestimmung im
alltag hier und wir wollen ja im eigenen
haus sein ja und das ist genau dieser
wunsch herr im eigenen haus zu sein der
ja auch ein ausdruck von dem streben
nach autonomie ist und das unvermögen
oder die hindernisse die dazu führen
dass wir nicht herr oder frau im eigenen
haus und genau darüber versuche ich an
meinem buch zu schreiben über diese
spannung und die kommt per hand auf
wunderbar zum ausdruck wir und ich
wollte jetzt keine moralische bewertung
des sports aber ich wollte gerne zurück
an einen punkt nämlich an diesen punkt
dass wir verboten sind mit unseren
geschichten und beziehungen und das
unser leben und sterben ja immer auch
andere menschen tangiert und da frage
ich mich manchmal auch wie viel
selbstbestimmung darauf den seien
bezüglich des eigenen sterbens aber auch
bezüglich des eigenen lebens also sie
erzählen auch die geschichte von gauguin
dem berühmten maler der kommt ja auch
vor auch ein berühmtes beispiel der
philosophische literatur der sich
entscheidet zu malen für die malerei ins
ausland zu gehen auf den staat und seine
familie im stich lässt
also wie viel salz bestimmungen darf
sein wenn es auf kosten der anderen lied
ich versuche in meinem buch eine nicht
besonders realistische position zu
begründen
und natürlich gibt es grenzen der moral
also ich überhaupt als beispiel den
mafioso der auch einfach gegen gesetze
verstößt das da sind bestimmt grenzen
von selbstbestimmung auch moralische
grenzen von selbstbestimmung wie das in
beziehung aussieht ist ja durchaus
umstritten ist ja durchaus ein bereich
in unserer gesellschaft wo wir sagen
würden
hier gibt es zu recht unterschiedliche
ethische moralische auffassung
manche leute sagen man muss immer treu
sein manche leute sagen man muss auch
nicht immer so sein
manche leute sagen ja das malen ist
wichtiger ja sogar wir haben seine
bilder und ja es ist irgendwie sehr
schade dass seine frau und seine kinder
darunter leiden muss das können wir auch
kritisieren er hätte das ja vielleicht
auch anders organisieren können ja aber
man kann nicht außer diese ganz
generellen grenzen die auch grenzen des
rechts sind kann man innerhalb dieser
grenzen nur sehr schwer kritisieren wie
andere leute ihr leben leben
das tun wir und das ist auch richtig wir
können autonome entscheidungen immer
auch kritisieren von der anderen
perspektive aus aber die person die
autonome person hat gegebenenfalls die
besseren gründe frau resta wir sind am
ende unseres gesprächs und ich habe sie
so oft sagen hören da müssen wir genau
unterscheiden das hat mir einmal mehr
gezeigt philosophie ist die kunst der
genauigkeit des genauen unterscheiden
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
dankeschön vielen dank mein vergnügen
jetzt gleich geht es auf eine reise in
ein land in dem freiheit immer noch hart
erkämpft werden muss fünf iranische
fotografinnen und fotografen und gehen
die zensur mit viel herz und verstand
und gewähren einen unverstellten blick
auf irland
nächste woche beginnt unsere sommerpause
sie haben gelegenheit unsere schönsten
sendungen des letzten jahres neu zu
entdecken
vielleicht finden sie bei den gesprächen
mit richard david precht joel harari
oder eckart von hirschhausen auch noch
eine inspiration für eine sommerlektüre
wir sind zurück am 27 august
ich wünsche ihnen jetzt einen schönen
sommer
[Musik]